how's this for a piece of meta content  Abby for my team just texted me this  about the green screen I just did so I'm  going to green on green on her and all  of you and here's what this is yes Abby  that's exactly what we're doing here  every day I get excited about this  framework that I think so many more  people can be doing which is [ __ ] up  everyone debating on who's good or bad  humans should because they are capable  of both being selfish and selfless I get  enormous joy out of making content that  leads to good business opportunities and  things for me and my family I equally  equally and I would even say maybe  slightly more enjoy the [ __ ] out of  making content that I know could help  someone I know a lot of people listen  and consume my content I know that me  talking about upcoming recessions may  lead to smarter decisions so I got  tremendous joy out of that just like  making this brought me joy too  [Music]